our thoughts and prayers with the three
families
these movements are consistent with
deliberate action by someone on the
plane
the operation has entered a new phase
the search was already a highly complex
multinational effort that has now become
even more difficult my emotion is going
through on a roller coaster ride
in the early hours of Saturday the 8th
of March Malaysia Airlines flight 370
vanished into the night an hour into its
journey came forth words from the flight
deck okay
received good night and with that it was
gone this program will look back at the
search so far and how it has expanded to
cover one tenth of the world's surface
we will also examine what we know about
the pilots and the passengers on board
and explore the theories of what might
have happened to this plane on what
should have been a routine flight from
Kuala Lumpur to Beijing rescue teams
from 25 countries are now involved in
the search for the missing plane dozens
of aircraft and ships are scouring the
ocean for a sign a clue anything
very difficult
however we never give up with lionesses
the operation initially centered around
the last-known location of the egg round
flight mh370 took off from Kuala Lumpur
Airport bound for Beijing on Saturday
the 8th of March at 12:41 a.m. local
time the last transmission from the
planes onboard communication system
ACARS was previously said to be at 7
minutes past 1:00 we've now learned that
it could have been switched off up to 30
minutes later it has also been revealed
that the last verbal contact from the
plane to air traffic control was at 19
minutes past 111 minutes earlier than
previously said and it has emerged for
the first time as well that the last
words from the cockpit were spoken by
the copilot before the planes
transponder which tracks it was turned
off at 1:30 a.m. air traffic control in
kuala lumper spoke to the flight deck
we've handed you over to Ho Chi Minh air
traffic control was the message ok
received good night was the reply it was
the last anyone heard
an oil slick aroused interest early in
the investigation but was then dismissed
it had nothing to do with the plane so
to some floating debris ad or perhaps
not so on closer inspection and in
another twist a possible hope satellite
images appeared to show smoke rising
from the ocean south of Vietnam but like
so many leads in this investigation
it was quickly dashed usual telltale
from any airplane that crashes into the
sea
the one thing that immediately floats
seat cushions they're not tied down they
they they will have their hull breaks up
seat cushions will be floating
everywhere that's been a trademark of
aircraft crashing into the sea
whatever the fate of flight mh370 the
pilots will have played some role fifty
three-year-old zaharie ahmad shah was
the captain that evening he is a vastly
experienced pilot with more than
eighteen and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt it was a volunteer
in the community program that I
organized at the end of the program
there was this guy helping to spec
chance to clean up that place and not
having met him before I asked who is
this man and I was told he works for
Malaysian Airlines I went to say thank
you to him and he introduced himself he
didn't mean his name card and when I saw
he was a captain of a triple7 you know
that's the kind of humble person that
captain's the holidays the first officer
was Fariq Abdul Hamid he's 27 years old
and joined Malaysia Airlines in 2007 he
was fairly new to this model of aircraft
a Boeing triple7
200 CCTV shows the two men going through
security on their way to board the
flight that evening we are told they did
not specifically request to fly together
that night
police have started searching their
homes talking to friends and neighbors
this is captain zaharie's house
and a smart compound on the outskirts of
Kuala lumper his maid looks out at the
door they found this simulator in
captain zaharie's house the data on it
is now being analyzed for clues as a
friend my emotion is going through what
I call the roller-coaster ride when you
hear of us a potential answer a positive
answer he goes up and then there is no
it goes back down and go Simon goes down
and yeah it's difficult and I can just
sympathize with the families of the
people involved now because they must be
going through much much more difficult
time
the longer the search goes on theories
that might have been initially dismissed
as outlandish are now being treated as
credible every day the authorities brief
the waiting families on the latest in
the investigation but with no sign of
the plane the grief is becoming
unbearable emotions are running high
well I'm gonna work I mean I've been
avoiding their responsibilities and
talking nonsense there are a lot of
contradictory answers to our questions
that makes us very angry I'm angry that
the Malaysians don't tell the truth they
lie to the whole world
I'm totally frustrated about this where
is my son
even taxis have GPS they can be found if
they are lost or stolen it's a huge
plane so high-tech
and so advanced how could it not be
found it's a joke split start emerging
within the search operation - we are
facing difficulties because the location
where the Malaysian plane lost contact
was inaccurate our search operations
life reliable basis and are untargeted
there is excessive information from
various channels one minute something is
found the next it's denied this kind of
false news is too much and has greatly
affected our decisions and then finally
some news a press conference is called
in Beijing the families prepared to
watch it nervously expectantly
a week to the day that flight mh370 went
missing with speculation running wild
and desperation growing the Malaysian
Prime Minister Najib Razak reveals to
the world major new developments we can
say with a high degree of certainty that
the aircraft communications addressing
and reporting system or acres was
disabled just before the aircraft which
the east coast of Peninsular Malaysia
shortly afterwards
near the border between Malaysia and
Vietnamese air traffic control the
aircraft's transponder was switched on
it then flew in a westerly direction
back over Peninsular Malaysia before
turning Northwest until the point at
which it left military primary radar
coverage these movements are consistent
with deliberate action by someone on the
plane the search of the South China Sea
is now over but rescue teams face the
prospect of a new area which is much
bigger much harder
according to the new data the last
confirmed communication between a plane
and the satellite was at 8:11 a.m.
Malaysian time on Saturday 8 March the
investigation team is making further
calculations which will indicate how far
the aircraft may have flown after the
last point of contact this will help us
to refine the search
this has now become a criminal
investigation but is it a murder inquiry
for the first time since the plane went
missing the prospect that it has landed
somewhere has become a genuine
possibility next who else was on board
the flight might the passenger manifest
all the answers to so many questions
my emotion is going through what a
roller coaster ride these movements are
consistent with deliberate action by
someone on the plane what happened to
Malaysia Airlines mh370 has continued to
battle the world rescue teams are
searching an area more than 10 million
square miles with the task they face is
daunting
within that vast space they are looking
for an object which even in one piece is
only 63 meters long a Boeing triple7
airline this program has examined the
search so far and the identity of the
two pilots flying the aircraft
it will now look at the other people on
board the passengers and the question
that everybody wants an answer to
could the flight manifest hold the
answers investigators are scrutinizing
every name on it but remarkably they've
admitted that they still haven't
received details for each passenger
after all this time so what do we really
know about the 227 passengers on board
who might have caused a hijacking
airliner who indeed has the knowledge 15
different nationalities were flying to
Beijing that night among them 153 from
China 38 from Malaysia five Indians four
French
three Americans and two Iranian zhan
board who became initial suspects but
seemed for the moment at least to have
been ruled out a texas-based company
Freescale Semiconductor had 20 employees
on board they are now missing passenger
manifest is obviously very important it
enables you to identify all the persons
that are on board the aircraft and that
obviously is important for the security
of the aircraft early in the
investigation to name stood out an
Austrian called Christian kozol the
other an Italian Luigi morality they
shouldn't have been listed they weren't
on board their passports had been stolen
in Thailand it would appear they were
then used by these two men Perrine or
Mohammed II and de la var sayyed
mohammad reza Iranians trying to claim
asylum in Europe they have no known
links to terrorism though we know that
once these two individuals arrived in
Kuala Lumpur on a 28th of February they
boarded flight 370 using different
identities
salamat bin omar has been waiting at at
kuala lumpur hotel for any news
his son was on board the plane he's an
aviation engineer and was on his way to
Beijing to repair private jets because
he obviously has knowledge of aircraft
he is also now under suspicion when the
news came about it broke my heart
because the aircraft was lost he didn't
fall he didn't crash it just disappeared
sorry my mop aha
yes I understand and we do hope that the
investigators do investigate in my
opinion all I know is that my son is an
engineer for private jet and not huge
boeing claims
let's recap the planes last known
movements flight mh370 took off from
Kuala lumper Airport for Beijing on
Saturday the 8th of March at 12:41 a.m.
local time the last transmission from
the planes onboard communication system
ACARS was previously said to be 7
minutes past 1:00 when out although it
could have been switched off up to 30
minutes later it has also been revealed
that the last verbal contact from the
plane to air traffic control was at 19
minutes past 111 minutes earlier than
previously said it is emerged for the
first time as well that the last words
from the cockpit were spoken by the
copilot before the planes transponder
which tracks it was turned off the next
known location for the airliner came
after it turned west it was picked up on
military radar over the Andaman Sea
after that its location is unknown but
we do know that a satellite received a
signal from the plane at 11 minutes past
8:00 in the morning from a distance that
puts it in one of two flight corridors
according to new information
investigators believe that if the plane
flew along the northern corridor it
would have reached from Laos to the
Caspian Sea depending on how fast it was
flying to the south the search spans
from Sumatra in Indonesia to the
southern Indian Ocean some of the
deepest waters on earth we also know
that the plane had enough fuel to fly
for around five hours after it was last
seen on radar off Malaysia depending on
the altitude it was flying that would
mean we could have traveled in
we're within this range it leaves a
likely search area covering a huge
swathe of the globe there's going to be
some systematic searching bye-bye-bye
military crimes as aircraft which quite
frankly will be the best systems
available much of the space technology
is not necessarily directed at the area
that the aircraft is believed to have
gone down and it's not necessarily going
to be the right kind of space-based
surveillance system to pick up the kind
of debris or clues to the existence of a
crashed aircraft so I think it will rely
very much on the on the numbers of
reconnaissance at maritime
reconnaissance aircraft that are now
flocking to help the Malaysians with
their search based on the data we know
it has been calculated that the plane
could have landed at one of six hundred
and thirty-four runways in 26 countries
across the region if that is it was
capable of doing so but India Pakistan
Kazakhstan and Kyrgyzstan have said
they'd detect any suspicious aircraft
movement in their airspace
the Malaysian Prime Minister has
confirmed the a car system was probably
disabled but what does that mean
aircraft communications addressing and
reporting system or a cars for short is
a computer which sends constant updates
to the ground about the health of a
plane it will first try to communicate
over radio frequencies before choosing
to send signals back via a satellite
network called SATCOM pilots can choose
to request data and to send it the
system will also send automated messages
throughout the flight for these systems
to be active airlines have to pay for
companies to run them but the systems
are built into all aircraft so just
because you don't pay for the service it
doesn't mean it won't try to transmit
data it is very easy for someone to pull
the circuit breaker on the planes
transponder which sends electronic
replies to the ground when it receives a
radio signal they could also do the same
on the a car system but despite all this
the SATCOM antenna will still
automatically ping away trying to find a
satellite to log on to as long as there
is hope the search will go on that is
the promise of the Chinese premier no
less but even with all the resources
that super power is dedicating to the
cause the fate of the Malaysia Airlines
flight remains unknown the families wait
longing for any small sign the clue the
marker anything in the dark of a calm
Kuala lumper night mh370 took off on a
routine flight north an hour later it
vanished in what must be the greatest
aviation mystery of recent times